one of the most expensive homes globally
is going up for auction at almost a
fifty percent discount the one belair
which is built by niall nyami who is a
former film producer turned real estate
developer he purchased eight acres of
land for 28 million dollars in one of
the most exclusive neighborhoods in the
united states he's building a home that
is reportedly worth 500 million dollars
but he has taken out tens of millions of
dollars in loans and has since defaulted
on almost 170 million dollars of loans
and debt now last year the house went
into chapter 11 bankruptcy protection in
october which means that is now going to
be set up for auction to the highest
bidder it's a no reserve auction so no
minimum bid is required the house is
incredible it's 105 000 square feet the
master bedroom is 5 500 square feet
alone it has 21 bedrooms and 49
bathrooms it has a movie theater a
garage four-lane bowling alley a bar a
nightclub everything you could possibly
want even a 10 000
bottle wine cellar next to the dining
room this week the house finally went up
for sale at 295 million dollars but if
it doesn't sell which it most likely is
looking like it won't it will be up for
auction online for a reported 250
million dollar sale price this is truly
one of the most incredible homes in the
world but whoever buys this home is
gonna have to spend tens of millions of
dollars and almost a year to renovate it
and finish the property now thinking
about it why didn't i all do this he did
this because he has ambitions that are
beyond measure it is an incredible
property and we will see where the
bidding ends now will this be a good
return on the investment i personally
think not whoever purchases home will
have to purchase it for probably around
200 and 300 million dollars spend
another tens of millions of dollars
renovating the property and will they be
able to sell the property who knows but
most likely not because it will be
personalized in one of the most
expensive real estate markets in the
world